if I have no brand on a t-shirt the
likely that someone buys it is low if I
put a Nike Swoosh on it the likely that
someone buys it is high if you go back
to what brand originally was brand was
like what you seared onto a cattle right
it was a brand and so if you have two
cows and one of them has a brand and the
other one does it why do we do that they
did that because it would change the
person who was looking at its behavior
and so if I look at a cow that doesn't
have a brand I'm like I might have that
cow that might be my cow I might take
that cow for myself but if you see a
brand that's got you know Tom's thing on
he might return it be like oh this is
Tom's cow I'm not going to mess with it
cuz it's Tom's cow it has his brand on
it and so the point of brand is to
change Behavior at scale that brand over
lots of time of branding has changed the
behavior of zillions of people and so
when you are branding you're just
associating an idea that people don't
know about and then we have to teach the
masses so like branding is really just a
teaching process of associating things
they don't know with things they do
know